I had some food earlier and I think it like is all gooped up
in my throat it's so gross to say
that's kind of icky to say sorry
First and foremost, I feel like I should probably put a pin
message.
If you are watching the game awards, I don't care.
I forgot about it.
I'll be honest.
I know everyone and their mother is doing a watch along, but
please, I don't, please, let's keep the conversation related
to the game.
Thank you.
So.
so yeah hold on let me say let me just say um wait where's
my mod at we have a guest mod today scarlet are you there i
gave you the wrench for today where are you oh i'm writing
the mess
I fear if people come in and are kind of obnoxious about it
because you know how people can be where it's just like such
and such got announced at the game awards or or such and
such won the game awards that's really great I don't even
know it's nominated for the game you know what all I care is
last year my my goat won astro bot game of the of my
afterlife not really but thank you I I'll just pin this.
Pin message.
So everybody, Scarlet answered the call when I asked for a
mod quickly before stream.
So, they'll be our guest mod for today.
Thanks, Scarlet.
Thank you, thank you.
So, yeah, we'll just...
If you see anybody talking about the Game of Wars, I
probably should have put it as like a muted thing.
I really don't care.
But, it's okay.
If you see anybody...
being a little bit obnoxious about it.
Feel free to time them out.
This game won the Game Award for Best Narrative back in
2017.
I feel like...
I think I confused this game for something else.
I don't know why.
I was just like, oh, this game doesn't seem very like what
I'm interested in playing.
And...
And... So I had never touched it.
I never watched it.
anyone play it I don't know literally anything about this
game I think I like I said I think I confused it for
something else so the disappearance of Ethan Carter I don't
know that one either maybe but uh yeah so I'm going in
completely blind please no spoilers or anything I saw some
people talking about that...
The, uh...
I guess the, um...
What's the word?
Subject matters, uh...
The disappearance of Haruki Suzumiya.
That's the one!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
That's the one I was confusing it for!
Yeah, yeah!
Yeah, L-M- Oh, what was I saying?
Uh...
My company give me free buddy.
Yes!
Yay!
Thank you!
So, going in completely blind, we'll see how it goes.
Content warning for intense subject matter surrounding death
and grief.
Well, I'm dead, too, so...
You know.
I guess, uh...
Yeah.
I guess we're fine.
cool I ran out of advice So watch Minto instead Yippee Let's
get into it then Let's play the game Are you grieving
though?
I'm grieving I'm grieving The The Oh my gosh What was I
eating?
Oh the grape that I dropped on the ground
I'm grieving the grape that I dropped on the ground and I
didn't get to eat.
I'll never...
Sambyoruru.
But my cats...
They walk around.
And...
They step where they shit, so...
It's really hard.
The three-second rule...
They have a lot of hair.
I try to vacuum, but they're littered.
It's just constantly everywhere.
And so, my grape is so delicious and juicy and sour.
Exactly how I like it.
And you know, I say that about my cats, but I let them in my
bed.
I let them sleep with me.
I think.
I'm covered in cat poo all the time.
Anyway.
Okay, let's play the game!
Oh.
What the remains of Edith Finch.
Am I Edith Finch?
Am I playing the game now?
Oh.
Open.
My journal.
Hey, I'm reading something.
Well, this is my journal, right?
Wait, how do I open the journal?
Open, there we go.
A lot of this isn't going to make sense to you.
And I'm sorry about that.
I'm just gonna start at the beginning with the house.
Happy birthday, Amy!
Happy birthday!
Oh, the house.
Wait, does this game have subtitles?
One second.
I, okay, I forgot to change every thing.
Hopefully, hopefully we're okay.
Oh, I don't see any subtitles.
It does?
But where?
They show up in-game.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
I'll just turn it up a bit.
We can turn the music down, like, a smidgen.
And then we do that.
I finally played Delta my first time playing any MGS game
inspired by you.
Finally got to see the original meeting of Ocelot and stuff.
obsession better.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Someone had put up a chain link fence, but it looked like I
wasn't the first person to hop it.
Oh, okay.
Wait, why are we hopping?
My brother Milton disappeared when I was four.
It was like the house just swallowed him up.
Now she's loud.
Holy cow.
Look at his little crown.
Date missing.
October 23rd, 2003.
May 19th, 1992.
He's last seen in Orca's Island?
Orca!
He was 11.
Oh, wait, I'm sorry.
Wait, he's 5...
I'm sorry, 4 foot 6 at 11 years old.
Whoa.
Wait, is that running or is zooming in?
Can I walk faster?
I lived here until I was 11, but I wasn't allowed inside
half the rooms.
Uh, yeah, it looks like a OSHA nightmare.
Well, I guess OSHA wouldn't really be involved if it's a
house, but still.
Oh my god, Orca's Island Gazette!
It's full of Yuri.
Help you well, Minta.
Thank you, you too!
Open.
Inside the mailbox were bills from seven years ago.
Marked urgent.
Open immediately.
No one opened them.
Games like this?
What are those?
The games like, what's it called?
Do this too.
It can talk.
Hey there.
You're going to pay these?
I think you're about to lose your house and all you own.
Yeah, like heavy rain.
Yeah, yeah, the Quantic Dream Games.
And David Cage and David Cage.
How do I get out of this?
Oh, okay.
No trespassing.
I've had me back since my brother Lewis's funeral.
But it's always...
Oh, dang.
You think this is real?
I mean, it's my property, you know?
Ribbit.
How is the audio?
Just feel free to shout if I need to adjust anything.
Inner will.
My mother left me a key, but didn't tell me what I'd
unlocked.
Ah.
Maybe she thought I'd know.
Or she thought the mystery would be enough to bring me back.
Oh.
That and clear?
Okay.
If you're like, Minto, game way quiet.
Feel free to say something.
Orca's Island is an actual place right across from Canada.
What the...
Pilgrimage?
We should all go.
No one had driven this way in a long time.
But I saw a few hoof prints.
Hoof prints?
That is a ye old 2000 something.
oh dear
I have a few deer around my truth is even after I inherited
the house I never thought I'd come back to it I have a few
deer around my maid cafe and I saw one last night I see them
quite often actually I take walks I'm just like haunting
around the neighborhood haunting around the neighborhood Oh
my gosh!
We gotta do Christmas karaoke soon!
Santa baby Minto, she's defrosting.
But, um...
Uh, I saw one last night, actually.
I know my questions about my family, but only the house knew
the answers to.
Excuse me, Edith.
I'm trying to speak.
I saw one last night, and it had...
It had horns!
And I had not seen any of them with horns up until now.
Wait, I wonder where the other pathway went to, though.
I wish I could run.
Ribbit.
This place is nice.
The house was exactly like I remembered it.
Well, not that part.
The way I could tell you about it.
Warrens or antlers?
Oh, antlers.
Sorry.
You mean antlers?
Yeah, yeah, antlers.
There's another missing poster in there.
there it's kind of sad not kind of it's quite sad but oh my
god there's a lot of them
ribbit ribbit ribbit ribbit ribbit ribbit as a child the
house made me uncomfortable in a way i couldn't put into
words um it's like the winchester mansion but worse
Okay, hold on.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna do this.
Real quick.
One second, sorry, guys.
One second.
Bb-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b.
Hmm?
There we go.
Save.
Okay.
Are you blacklisting the word?
Yes.
I'm already tired of it.
Coladena!
Thank you so much for the bargain, thank you!
Some days, it's easier for me to ignore things, but... I
asked Edie once about the dragon in the pond.
This girl is always interrupting.
She said it killed her husband.
It killed her husband?
I was six.
It seemed like an odd joke to me, even then.
Why do you hate...
Why do you hate the dragon in the pond?
The dragon in the pond killed her.
kill your grandma.
But, um, yeah, I'm only former human.
You got...
As a 17-year-old.
Say anything!
I knew exactly what those words were.
I was afraid of the house.
Mito, I don't think you're going to be able to talk much
today.
It seems...
It seems like it.
But yeah.
I was just saying...
Some days, some things are easier to ignore.
Some days, things are easier to ignore for me.
But I've been a little...
Many things on the brain.
So I'm a little frazzled.
And sometimes it's hard for me to ignore things without it
bothering me.
So I just block.
What's going on here?
Doggy door.
Perfect size for me.
Wait.
are we oh the doggy door used to be a lot easier when I was
the power had been turned off the night we left I didn't
expect her to actually go through the doggy door okay Gary's
potting mix There's so much in here.
Cosmic cuisine.
The pleasures of Japanese cooking.
Okay, someone.
Gordon Ramsay over here.
Anybody?
No.
Is this how...
I always thought this was a horror game.
Is it not?
Does this game get spooky?
Oh my god.
The tennis...
There's something...
Wait, I hear creaking, though.
Kind of scary.
Copy.
Thank you so much for the thank you.
Thank you.
Not spooky, just heavy.
Not horror, horror.
Oh, okay, okay.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
There's something so extremely nostalgic about seeing a
tennis ball on like the garage cord like what?
The cord is connected to nothing.
Wait.
But did you guys have families that did that too that would
put a tennis ball on the...
Oh wait, who raided?
Thank you for the ra- Oh, VB!
Hi!
Thank you, Jace, for the five gifts, and thank you.
I call this nostalgic horror.
Oh, God.
So it just makes you sad and old?
For the first time in years.
Yeah?
I felt like I was home.
Ray Mack, thank you.
2010, so they left in.
Oh, look, here we go.
Eddie, Dawn, Lewis, Milton, Edith.
Oh, they're eating lots of beans.
Or canary?
Canary?
What are they eating?
Tuna?
But instead of a family, there were just memories of one.
Oh, beautiful and sad.
Oh.
In loving memory of Louis Finch.
November 21st, 2010.
Beloved brother to Edith, son of Dawn.
Great grandson to Eddie.
Oh, look.
Lewis.
Oh, gosh, there's so many names here.
Okay, I'm going to do my best, you guys.
I'm...
When they give me so many names like this, I'm going to be
in trouble, maybe a little bit.
For the house being abandoned for so long, though, it looks
great.
Apple pie!
You don't really have to worry about remembering?
I don't?
Okay.
the table was still a wreck from the night we left why did
they leave in such a hurry like what's going on here that
doesn't like a bomb had gone off killing everyone but
sparing the furniture that's a little that's a little brutal
oh it's wine okay
they love Chinese food so glad you're playing this as one of
my faves yeah I'm excited to check it out Tissues prepared?
Wait, I don't have tissues.
None, thank you, but please don't.
Thank you.
Nothing in the house looked abnormal.
There was just too much of it, like a smile with too many
teeth.
Oh, they had a pet even.
Even the fireplace had a story.
Edie told me the bricks came from the original house after
it sank.
Sank?
oh my god get this house away from the the the lake okay
there's so much stuff it's just clutter everywhere there's
so much stuff what's this Barbara the tennis ball was a grip
to prevent thieves people could stick a coat great Sven
builds a music box for Barbara along with the rest of the
house wait seriously
oh my gosh the Yeti watch out watch out behind you watch out
there's a there's a Bigfoot behind you I kind of want the
Barbara Bigfoot music box Barbara Finch she's a movie
director of the basement so I wasn't too surprised when the
key didn't fit ah okay I was thinking can we unlock the
front door now instead of going in in through the doggy door
like a like a savage my mom wasn't much of an optimist but
she never stopped believing that my brother Milton was alive
Where'd he go?
What happened to him?
No mail for Milton!
Wait, that's so kind of...
What 11-year-old is getting mail anyway?
A lot of things got left behind in the whirlwind of that
last night.
Whoa!
Wait, is this sealed?
Eadie told me once that every Finch who ever lived is buried
somewhere in the library.
Uh, Milton?
Milton, you in there?
Whoa.
It's kind of freaky.
I wouldn't want to know that.
As a child, that would make me very afraid.
After Milton disappeared, Mom sealed up all the bedrooms.
Then Edie retaliated and drilled peepholes.
Why would she seal up the bedrooms, though?
Oh, God!
would scare me every night.
That is terrifying.
Look at... Oh, my God!
Oh,
my God.
I guess we know what happened to Milton.
Like, imagine in the dark.
No, thank you.
Whose room is this?
Molly.
Molly always seemed like a girl I could imagine being
friends with.
If she hadn't died.
in 1947.
Definitely haunted.
Wait, so they just sealed up her room?
So if you die, your room gets sealed?
Is that what happens?
I don't hate the concept.
I think it's kind of neat.
You just keep building the house.
Someone dies.
You built another room.
Okay.
for them.
Barbara was a child star for two years.
Until America grew out of it.
Oh, wait, there's a bigfoot!
Oh my gosh, it really is a bigfoot and little girl!
Okay.
Oh.
Wow.
Oh, that's so cute.
She's like painting her own room.
Ugh.
Edie's father, Odin, built the original house.
You were one of the voices telling her to keep building.
The movie is called My Friend with Bigfoot.
Oh, wait.
My friend Bigfoot.
Why did I just say with?
I see it now.
Whenever people ask me about my family, the first thing they
always want to know about is Barbara.
Bill Bunting has Bigfoot.
Nice.
Is she a little girl there?
I guess she is.
Oh yeah, I was wondering that guy in the middle.
I just thought...
I just thought he was really ugly.
I wasn't gonna say anything.
I was like, ooh.
Ooh.
But he's...
Now it's okay.
It's just up his big foot.
Also, I remember that room over there.
I'm like exploring the ones that are...
Mom must have locked the third floor stairs on the night we
left.
I just wanted to look around first.
Okay, I guess we go to the fishy room.
Or wait, this one also has some sealed doors.
This one is question not sealed.
This one is not sealed.
Calvin was an astronaut.
Do wonder why they left, though.
Yeah, I guess we'll figure it out.
What's in here?
Calvin.
My grandpa Sam spent seven years sharing a room with his
dead brother.
Calvin.
Oh, Calvin was not an astronaut.
The body was removed, though, right?
Imagine just his mummified body in his bed.
I love books as much as the next person, but this house has
a crap ton of books, right?
There is no way.
There is no way they've gone through all...
There's no way they've read all of these.
It's an insane amount of books.
It's the most books I've ever seen in my entire afterlife.
The Spirit Among Us.
Who's this?
Gregory.
Why are they all children?
As a kid, I just assumed every house had peepholes and
sealed rooms you weren't allowed inside of.
was a bathroom wait what oh god the shag carpet is really
awful why is gregory uh i have so many questions oh gosh
they're like this family is like crazy eccentric hi miito
hello hello hello but edie the last time i was in edith
senior's room i was 10 and she was painting my portrait oh
Can we go in?
This one's not sealed.
Let me in.
Hmm.
Okay.
To the one room that's open.
Gregory lives in a pink bathroom, okay?
Okay.
I'm, you know, I was questioning.
I was about to say I'm not questioning it, but I definitely
questioned it.
I did.
Here we go.
I spent a lot of time playing in Great Uncle Walter's room.
I think my mom sometimes regretted not sealing it.
it up why did she seal up the rooms though after Milton
disappeared like what would that do Lewis told me there were
secret passages but I never believed him 20,000 leagues
under the sea open up
yeah this room's fine turns out my mom was really good at
keeping secrets this place would be a great Airbnb you know
Now it was time to find out what my mom had been afraid of.
Like all the themed rooms and everything, people would go
nutso over this.
This place would be an awful Airbnb.
To each their own.
When the themes on the wall, it was clear my brother Milton
had been here before me.
Oh yeah, it says Milton.
Some people would ruin it.
I guess that's true.
Is it crawling?
Reading this, maybe it sounds like I had a plan.
Is it that... I think you could stand.
I don't think the ceiling is that low.
Doggy door, doggy door, doggy door, doggy door.
Look at the door you entered.
Yeah, but like look at the ceiling.
We don't want to crawl anymore.
But I had no idea what was behind that door.
Oh my gosh.
It's, uh, the one girl's room.
Just like I had no idea where all this was going to lead.
Orca's Island cows.
Oh, you think the ants are still in there?
They escaped.
Owl.
I grew up looking at Molly's room through the peephole.
Being inside for the first time, I felt like I'd stepped
behind a painting.
Where is our room then?
Maybe I guess the third floor.
Molly's gerbil had a tiny bedroom with its own even tinier
gerbil cage.
That's so cute!
Oh, oh, I see it.
Oh, I thought the...
Oh, wait, that's so cute.
So the gerbil could go inside?
Oh, I thought there was like a hole drilled into this one
that allowed the gerbil to go inside.
That'd be so cute.
Let's see, what is Molly's?
Okay, Monsters of the Deep?
Okay!
The Weird Tale?
Magical Realist Fiction?
Okay, Molly.
Molly's got a...
Molly's a little strange.
We like it.
Bedbug.
Oh.
This room is in, like, a...
pristine condition like nothing what if something happens
like what if this window breaks the door is sealed what are
you supposed to do Mount Rainier can you get out there's no
dust yeah like it looks like it's been taken care of it says
the mothman or either
I am not judging.
I am saying that she is one of me.
She's one of us.
Hello.
Thank you so much, dear, for 20 months.
Thank you.
Orcas Island is a real place.
The local sports ball team is called the Vikings, though.
Not the Cavs.
Maybe they...
I got the sense 80 had spent a lot of time here before my
mom sealed the doors.
Oh.
What is that?
Molly, her diary?
Uh-oh.
Oh my god.
December 13th, 1947.
Dear diary, I'll be gone soon, but I wanted to tell somebody
about what's going to happen.
It started when mom sent me to bed without dinner.
I woke up and I was starving, so I looked around for
something to eat.
The gerbil.
No, no, don't do it, Molly.
Molly, don't do it!
I like the... Molly is such a... She's got a little... She's
very curious.
I like it.
I thought about eating Christopher, but I held back.
You held back?
How desperate are you, Molly?
Molly?
The gerbil food was dry, but I didn't mind it.
My Halloween candy was all gone.
I'm in shock.
Mom, can I come out now?
This is...
Sweetheart, it's late.
Go to sleep.
I'm so hungry, I'm eating gerbil food.
I think we should say...
I'm contemplating eating my live pet fish.
Almost two years.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait.
Oh, I can't see anything.
Oh my gosh, it's so dark.
Wait.
Please.
How tall?
Why am I so sure?
I kept eating and eating.
I ate a lot of things that night.
Are those real?
I think that's decorative, no.
Aren't those like made of foam usually?
They're not real.
Berries, I don't think.
Then I heard chirping outside my window.
Are you gonna eat the bird?
It was a barn swallow going back to her nest.
Don't do it, Molly.
I reached out for her.
And suddenly...
I was a cat.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Best case scenario.
The sensitivity went like crazy.
Can I jump?
Oh, I can.
I'm purring, I'm purring.
I tried to be quiet, but the bird was really scared.
Where am, where's the bird?
Jump to where?
Oh, there.
Um, up there?
We're going?
Oh, why'd you come to me?
We're the worst cat ever!
I jumped and I almost got her.
Turning into a cat who does that, suddenly anamorphs?
I could tell she was getting really tired.
I was up in the big tree I promised that I wouldn't climb it
anymore This thing All I cared about was eating that mama
bird You used to climb this thing?
Oh my god
That's terrifying I gobbled her up And suddenly I was an owl
First all I heard was the wind Then I heard Little teeth
nibbling in the grass.
Where?
I don't hear anything.
Am I searching for teeth?
Little teeth nibbling in the grass?
Rabbits.
Rabbits this way.
Oh, I see them.
You can't escape me, little rabbit.
Or you can, because I don't know how to go down.
You're mine, little rabbit.
it you're mine you're mine too fast too fast oh there's one
oh he's glitching out
you're mine you're mine oh there we go i have to do
something
i imagined his face looking up and seeing mine through my
talents I pulled him up and I didn't chew one bit.
And then I blew off to find something bigger.
Bigger?
She's her greed.
She's insatiable.
In one bite.
Didn't even savor the rabbit.
A mama rabbit.
Oh, catch two rabbits with only two swoops.
You can miss?
I started choking, but I couldn't stop eating.
Is she hallucinating because of the- Oh my god!
Oh.
Uh.
Up a
cliff and into the ocean.
Now.
I was hungrier than ever.
Yes, yes.
I see that.
Oh.
I see that little fish.
Little fish, little fish.
That's not a fish.
That's a seal.
I wanted fat, juicy seals.
He's right there.
Oh my gosh.
Well, I'm not going to get the achievement on this guy.
Oh.
Oh my god.
flipper and it tasted really good what about the rest don't
waste food oh there it is tasted really good blood in the
water blood in the water wait I thought we tore it off
though I
grabbed on tight but I was so hungry I jumped out of the
water when When I opened my eyes, everything had changed.
Yeah?
What are we now?
We're...
A box?
No, we're still a shark.
Wait, what are we?
An octopus?
What are we?
Now I was a monster.
I smelled people everywhere.
Is that Christmas music?
It is, I think.
How timely.
Am I going the right way?
I can't go.
People!
Oh, person!
I moved real wide.
People!
I wanted to stop, but also, I didn't.
In the morning.
Oh, this guy.
This is...
Delicious.
Is she...
Oh my god, it's so loud.
Is she even eating them?
Wait, how do I get up?
to that guy oh there we go oh that to go around the longest
tentacle in history the last passenger i was still hungry
and across the water still something i had to have this is
technically another cannibal game
What am I now?
Oh, I'm still a tentacle.
I slithered onto the sand.
And the good smell went into an old pipe.
Ooh, we call that sewage.
We're gonna go down the pipe.
Up the pipe.
We're still tentacle.
Oh, I'm in the bathroom.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
She's really freaky.
It's just like...
Oh, my gosh.
Every girl watching will relate to this.
If you are a girl...
Well, actually, I think, I think boys too maybe, but girls
especially.
If you have a dog, like a, and that likes to get through
trash.
I got closer and closer.
You know.
Oh, wait, this is her room.
We went through a loop.
Yep, yep, yep.
Am I going the right way?
Wait, is it?
Ah, thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you!
Hello, hello!
As a guy who grew up with two sisters, yeah.
All my stomach started growling.
All of them!
How many you got?
And suddenly, that was me again.
I held my breath for
all of me to fall asleep.
But it's not going to wait much longer.
It needs to be, and we both know, I will be delicious.
Thank you guys so much for the gift, and thank you.
Molly?
I'm not sure if I believed all of that, but I'm sure Edy
would have.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Close the book!
Oh, that was the sound of...
A cat, no?
It is a cat!
I think the implication is that Molly died from eating
poisonous mistletoe, and this was a hallucination of her
final moments.
Yeah, that would make sense.
Oh no!
I... I wanted to look in the bathroom, but I...
Okay.
My bad.
Too bad.
I missed my chance.
This would be obvious later, but my mom never told me any of
these stories.
Edie would have, but mom didn't like bringing up the past.
Though, when we adopted a stray kitten, she was the one who
named it Molly.
Aw.
What?
I spent a lot of time in Great Grandma Edie's room.
Oh, we're in here now.
when edie told people sven was killed by a dragon she could
also have said he was building a dragon shape slide that
collapsed she could have but she didn't she just wanted to
be all whimsical why did she have so many gnomes thank you
so much for the pink p-i-c-a a disorder that causes people
to eat random objects excessively her mom locked to punish
her, but that allowed her to eat stuff unsupervised.
It was an accident.
Oh, I've never heard of that before.
Interpreted as to mean that Molly was undiagnosed P-I-C.
Pika.
For now it's like Pika.
Oh, I've never heard of that before.
So I go, thank you so much for the five gifted.
I don't know, though.
I feel like she was attempting to eat things that were real
food though, right?
Well, I mean, fish is technically a food and the gerbil food
is food for a gerbil and then she tried to eat berries.
Oh, the toothpaste.
It still goes in your mouth, though.
Built 1937.
Sven for Eadie won't go!
One summer they evacuated the island, but Eadie refused to
go for a few weeks.
She was a celebrity.
Fifteen cents!
Wow.
The mysteries of death and thereafter.
Well, Miss Eadie, I could...
What the...
Eadie gave a big interview about a mole man living under the
Finch house.
mom was furious.
Wait, I want to win a family day out at Druid World!
Oh, well, thank you so much for that, so many, thank you!
I hadn't thought of myself as Edith Jr. for a long, long
time.
Oh.
Let's see.
We got Edith Jr. Lake Trip, my friend Bigfoot, Edith
Interview, Random Junk, Sam Ceremony, Sam Photo award
conspiracy now weird america the the finches oh my gosh home
movies molly concepts what does that mean oh this is uh oh
purply lurpy rub is that a lizard no That's so sad.
Aww.
Oh!
Furpy!
Mystery!
Derpy!
The bird names are so Furpy!
Zerpy!
Those view is so nice though.
Sims names truly Lewis died a week before we left but Edie
had already started to memorialize him
okay tell me if you guys see this too because it's not like
a fully completed painting see where his chin is it looks
like a really long dog nose do you guys see Or like, like a
snout of some sort.
And he looks like he's giving me a little bit of bedroom
eyes.
And he's like, I'm a sexy rat.
Edie knit me a new pair of gloves every year.
Just in time to replace the old ones.
Aww.
I can't unsee it.
He had to let me do it for you, dog.
Let me do it for you.
It's a big family, huh?
Holy moly.
Lewis, oh.
Her room was like a museum.
Oh, wait.
Isn't that the guy that's in the...
Oh my gosh, another gnome.
Or...
Uh...
Okay, here we go.
We're looking through.
For 500 years, the Finches have been famous throughout
Norway for their fortune and misfortune.
Odin Finch buries the latest victims of the family curse,
his wife Ingeborg and their newborn son, Johann.
On January 7, 1937, he set sail with his family and his
house, hoping to leave the curse behind.
That's right, that's just his whole house.
on a boat oh my gosh oh but 40 foot waves off the coast of
Washington send the house and Odin to the bottom of the sea
they were Norwegian gnomes are big in that folklore yeah
yeah it's true Odin's daughter Edie with husband Sven and
baby Molly step ashore on their new home Orcus Island Odin
Finch is the first to be buried in the new family cemetery
did he make it or his daughter edie is already dreaming of a
new finch house oh give me out of here oh sorry give me out
there we go the controls in this game are a little
whatever's wrong with this family it goes back a long ways
he drowned in the 40
Like I have to do with my mouse, like I have to swipe it,
you know?
You'll get used to it?
Where do we go from here?
Out the window again?
Wait, there's this door over here, too.
Even in your 90s.
Sometimes Edie seemed a lot younger than my mother.
Aww.
Is that a ghost?
Let me check the window real quick.
There's like cords going everywhere.
That's you.
Oh, gosh.
We're in Gregory's room.
It's terrible.
The only trace Grandpa Sam's first wife, Kay, left on the
house was the pink bathroom.
Oh.
It was a pretty big trace.
It's so terrible.
Oh, cute.
That's, like, fun to play with in the bathtub.
I'm just saying.
Oh, grandma needs the chair.
I think I remember my grandpa having a chair in his shower.
Like that.
I always be like, why?
What is this?
Oh my god.
Why would you like have a picture of the death of the house?
Like that.
It's pink.
Yeah, so they don't fall.
Yeah, yeah.
I didn't know why before, but I get it now.
There's a secret.
in this bathroom by Sven and Edie Finch.
I don't, maybe if you make it really obvious, people will
overlook it, you know?
There's a secret in this bathroom.
Oh.
It's in the last place you would look.
It isn't in the cupboard.
It's hidden in this book.
Oh, oh.
Whoa!
So cool!
Calvin Finch.
Some guy.
Sven gave Sam an old camera he'd refurbished.
He never put it down.
Who's Sam?
Is that Sam?
Well, I guess so.
Why is Sam in the...
in the...
in the walls.
Sam is living in the walls.
Didn't mean to disrupt your stream.
Wasn't even my phone saying I didn't notice the thing.
It's okay.
Thank you, though.
You're totally good.
I appreciate it, though.
Thanks, Nan.
Have fun.
Milton.
Is that a...
Oh, that's a... Wait.
Does whiskey come in wine bottles like that?
Oh, my gosh.
Is that a beer?
Push.
Where are we now?
Oh, we're in a...
Yeah, the room that he had to share with his dead brother or
whatever.
Oh, that's so sad.
Like, he kept growing, but his brother didn't.
Calvin, yes.
Okay, Sam is the grandpa.
Norway is the Atlantic Ocean, so either he sailed the North
Sea, an Arctic Ocean to reach west, or he crossed the
Atlantic, went South America.
Yeah, that's what I was wondering, too.
What?
Why didn't they go to the East Coast?
You can check the diary if you don't remember who's who.
Yeah, thank you, I will.
Fort Sam.
The secret lives of war photographers.
Aww.
This was before Google Maps.
Join and fight.
What's this say?
Samuel Finch.
I knew Grandpa Sam had a twin.
Oh, it was a twin?
That's even worse.
They say, they say like twins.
Oh wait, oh my gosh.
I thought that was Doom guy.
Twins are like so connected, you know.
And that he never talked about him.
Tool Command Center.
I guess my grandpa didn't like history anymore than my mom
did.
This is like the coolest room ever, though.
Oh my gosh.
This is the cool...
Wow, this is kind of sad, though.
Not kind of.
It's pretty sad.
But this is the coolest room ever!
The bridge, the stairs to the bridge to the, to the
spaceship room!
Awesome.
How I Want to Remember My Brother by Sam Finch.
The thing I remember is that when he made up his mind, that
was it.
My brother said he'd die before he ate another mushroom.
And he did.
Well...
At Barbara's funeral, we swore we'd never be afraid again.
And he wasn't.
It's making me a bit dizzy.
I think Calvin always wanted to fly.
He kept his promise.
Come!
Calvin!
Jeno's ready!
Coming!
But that day, he finally made up his mind to do it.
Oh my god!
I told him going around was impossible.
He already has a leg broken.
Maybe if I hadn't said that.
Oh my god, oh my god!
God, oh my God.
Every kid tried to do this, though.
I think, you know.
Maybe he's one time picked up.
Oh my God.
And maybe he'd still be here.
But I don't.
I think he'd already made up his mind.
The swing over a cliff.
That's what I want to remember about my brother.
There's many questionable decisions here.
Oh my god!
Hold on, Calvin!
Calvin's story felt strangely familiar.
When I was younger, I remember trying to do the exact same
thing.
Yeah, every kid did, right?
What a legend.
Holy cow!
Whoever told me that you can control this stuff with arrow
keys?
Thank you.
Instead of, like, trying to close the book with my mouth.
Edy roped off Calvin's half of the room.
What's in here?
He actually did it, the madman.
Wait, this is so cute too.
Cool.
Whoa!
This house is insane.
Oh my gosh, those aren't even real books I just noticed.
They're painted on.
We're back in the walls.
Eek!
Spooky.
The passages were a pretty tight fit.
They'd obviously been built for smaller hands and bellies.
Every kid did to fly off a cliff to avoid eating mushrooms
for dinner.
So real.
Oh, OK, we're here.
OK.
But why is there so much?
What is that?
Why is there so much alcohol in here?
If it's made for children.
Okay, okay.
We open up our little shortcut.
Alright, there we go.
Growing up, I always thought of Barbara as a child star.
Is that not what she was?
I thought there was a highlight on the bra, no?
Am I just seeing what I wanted to see?
I could have sworn there was.
like a little
I know I saw it I saw it no there was right the prompt to
climb out uh oh imagine making one movie and them making a
doll out of you because it was like such a famous movie
the music in here is Like the ambiance is...
Macaulay Colkin?
Oh, I guess you're right.
But he was in a series of movies.
The Home Alone series.
Like the Wizard of Oz.
No, I don't... That's a...
Julie Gar...
Garland, right?
Julie Gar... Right?
Judy.
Judy Garland, yeah.
I don't count her, because she was in quite a bit of stuff.
I mean, obviously, the Wizard...
But the Wizard of Oz is, like, a technical masterpiece.
Oh, my gosh, I love learning about, like, the tech, not the
tech, but, like, you know, the cinematography.
Just everything that went into making the Wizard of Oz is...
It's kind of insane, and also so...
Amazing.
Like, the part...
thing is um is uh the part where it goes from the sepia to
color there's a part where she has to like open the door and
it goes into the color the part right before that it looks
like it's in like the sepia tone but it's just the lighting
and like the special effects that they had to do like they
put her like in a different outfit and stuff it's so cool
It's so, oh my gosh, it's like so, like the way that they
had to technically do that is just, oh my god.
Didn't the guy who played the Tin Man get super cancer from
the makeup?
I think that is, I'm not sure about cancer.
I've heard that it's poisonous, but I think there were parts
of that that were exaggerated.
Yeah, practical effect, that's what I was thinking of, thank
you.
did not he did not die from the paint that is a rumor he
died from old age you guys it's incorrect that he died from
the paint yeah yeah so he died of rust so sad such is the
life of a tin man swan lake this thing though i don't know
do you think this movie would be I was, well, you know what,
I was gonna say, I don't think this movie would be popular,
but also in the Wizard of Oz, the costumes are kind of scary
too, so, you know, never mind, I don't know.
I never thought about how hard it must have been for her
afterwards.
Is that a role, or is that, like, is this a costume for a
movie, or is it a, uh, her actual work uniform, I wonder.
Oh, it was her birthday?
Birthday, Barbara.
Barb Street.
Why'd she have that on her bed?
This is such a cute room, though.
Free cake!
Guy and a speedo.
And popcorn that is so old, it's fused together.
That is popcorn, right?
It's got...
What?
I don't...
Can popcorn get that way?
How is the cake still in...
Well, the cake isn't really intact.
It's kind of moldy.
No, popcorn looks like an alien creature.
Dreadful stories.
Guest starring Barbara Finch.
Of all the stories people wrote about Barbara's death, I'm
surprised Edie saved this one.
About her death?
Wait, that's messed up.
Oh my gosh, these dang true crime podcasters coming in oh
jack here with another ghastly tale inspired by america's
most unfortunate family i'm calling it the surprise ending
of barbara finch is this guy supposed to be the crypt keeper
as a child star barbara was famous for her scream now at 16
she was all washed up her has been oh my god she's just
living her life she'd been asked to perform her signature
scream at a local convention for monster movie fans it was
just the boost her career needed not beast econ his scream
hadn't aged well
getting better i think you just need the right motivation
biggest fan and current boyfriend, Rick, was about to
demonstrate when...
Now that was a great scream.
It was Barbara's father.
Sven, he'd slipped into a table saw and had to be rushed to
the emergency room.
So Barbara got stuck babysitting her youngest brother,
Walter.
Her convention comeback was cancelled.
Okay, I'm hearing frustration, but I'm not hearing terror.
What if I tried?
A gang of hoodlums in Halloween masks have been terrorizing
Orca's Island tonight.
Oh my god!
Everything is happening all at once!
That came from the basement!
You're right!
Also, I loved your delivery on that.
Why is your basement door locked?
Because my dad likes making puzzles and secret passages.
There's a key hidden in the music box.
Oh!
and winding until finally the key pops up.
Thanks, babe.
We'll be back in a sec.
20 minutes later, Rick hadn't returned.
So Barbara went to look for him right on cue.
She reached for the music box.
Yeah?
Oh, I reach him.
And as she wound the key, she listened for Rick, but the
house was silent.
Oh, it's for the basement.
This is scary.
Oh my god, I'm in the book.
Not the music.
She found Rick's crutch and imagined the worst.
Hey, yeah.
Oh.
That's scary.
Not the hook man!
Car hook!
Wait, what about the ganged...
masked hooligans?
Wait, if I go down there, is there still gonna be blood?
Oh, this is the worst thing I've ever seen though.
My stream is already gonna get DMCA'd, so why not?
Keep it up for as long!
as i want
the stream is cooked i won't let them get me
I smack first.
Oh, it's letting...
Run!
Oh dear!
Oh!
Rick?
Barb, relax.
I was just trying to scare you to help you find your scream.
Oh dear.
I'm not scared, Rick.
I'm furious.
Then act furious.
All I'm getting from you now is that you're hurt and
confused and you...
Is this guy like a...
She threw him out.
But she kept a little something to remember him by.
His crutch?
Barb!
Have you seen my other crutch?
And she was still holding it.
And she fell asleep watching the late, late picture show.
Hours later...
Barbara!
Huh?
Walter?
What's going on up there?
Ah!
Huh?
Okay, I'm coming up.
But this is a trick for dead Walter.
Oh no.
Ha!
Look at the skelly over there.
It's not the music again.
They're gonna be like, there was a crime, there was a scene.
She was fighting for her life.
Can they even use this song?
Is it allowed?
I'm not letting them.
The scary guy on this side.
Okay, he's not.
Not there yet.
Is it yours?
Is it...
Oh, what?
Who's...
Oh, okay.
We gotta go this way.
Why is there two skeletons?
They're both like facing the same direction too.
Walter!
I'm here to save you!
Walter, are you there?
Vanished.
At his bedside radio, I still am.
Orca's Island police described the man is six feet tall with
a steel hook for a hand residents are urged to lock all
doors and windows and notify the police of any suspicious
activity oh my god oh my god Barbara turned saw the hook man
and was speechless he was quite smashing yeah get his ass
and he couldn't get enough of Barbara Okay, Barbara, there's
gotta be another way out of here.
But she played her part beautifully.
What?
It's funny because the bottom, kind of like, the little
panel kind of, uh, spoiled it.
Um, do I go in here?
Do I go out and confront him?
Years, the hinges grow.
Oh, no!
Oh.
Here I go!
He wasn't moving, but she sensed this story might not be
over yet.
Here I go.
I'm gonna go get his butt.
No surprises!
She
listened for his breathing, but all she heard was...
No surprises!
Maybe he's in here.
Dying to speak to young Barbara.
At the door, she heard whispering.
Whisperings?
It was coming from inside the house.
What is going on?
No, please.
Oh, dear.
Surprise!
The monsters, I come to surprise her.
Wait, what?
Barbara, it was a dream come true.
She saw what kind of monsters they were, and she realized
what was about to happen.
She was going to be famous, and with her final breath,
Barbara Finch gave the performance of her life.
She looked so happy about it.
I didn't care myself, but I hear Barbara.
was magnificent she found her scream she had a taste for
stardom but unfortunately so did her fans of course the
police blamed it all on poor rick who disappeared the same
night whoa and little walter hiding under his bed the whole
time oh that little punk he took it all pretty hard but
That's another story.
As for Barbara, tucked inside the music box is all they ever
found of her.
What?
Her ear.
Now that's what I call a real eerie tale.
Oh my
god!
At least put it back upright.
Edie told me all Barbara wanted was to be remembered.
as absurd as that comic was.
Maybe what Edie saw was a happy ending.
Freaky.
This one makes absolutely no sense to me.
I can see no rational way why Barbara could have died.
That doesn't seem absurd.
Right?
There's too many elements that I feel.
Like, there's no...
Because the narrator is so unreliable, you can't really
pinpoint, like, is the radio...
The radio talks about gangs en masse.
But then also talks about a hook man and then she has her
boyfriend there and then there's like so much going on But
also I feel so bad for her like Anyone who would think that
a child A child star sounds the exact same when they're an
adult What do you mean the child can't scream like a child
anymore when she's 16?
That's so stupid She's not a good actress anymore People are
so weird about that kind of stuff sometimes.
John Carpenter apparently agreed for the music to be in the
game.
Really?
Wait, that's kind of awesome then.
I guess now I know why mom doesn't like me playing with the
music box.
Yeah?
At the end, when she was all happy, she was thinking, what a
thrill or thrill or not.
It's kind of how it is with voice acting, too.
Yeah, yeah.
my my um my mom got scouted when she was a kid uh she used
to be a child actress they were like oh my gosh you have the
it thing but my grandma she worked in hollywood she was a
hollywood makeup person and she knew like she kind of saw
what the children child stars went through and like like the
adult even the adult actors and actresses what they went
through and so she was like nah i'm not letting you go
through that life
yeah is it getting darker you know i even turned up the
brightness in this game it was just by one but i'm kind of
glad i did good call i know right
hello oh i'm stuck i'm the slowest ever holy out time to go
into the basement
keep going can you speed run this game if you already know
this part don't
think so oh okay oh probably only lets you turn it so many
times right oh my gosh it's just like everything we saw in
the comic i miss my crutch i miss my crutch i miss my crutch
of safety.
At least those creepy things.
There's just a couple gnomes.
That's it.
Some wood.
Mom said the basement was off limits.
Unless I wanted another tetanus shot.
I feel so defenseless without it.
I know.
Realistically, couldn't you just smash the glass pin?
I think we're trying to avoid vandalism, right?
Oh my god, he built a mini dragon, too.
He built a big dragon.
A mini dragon.
dragon to then build the big dragon.
I saw Edie sneak down to the basement once carrying
packages.
It's so dark.
Can you guys see?
I thought maybe she was hiding presents.
I knew exactly where my mom would hide presents.
Every year.
She turned to the same place.
Pretty well, actually.
Oh, awesome.
As long as you guys can see.
it turned out she was hiding a lot more than that oh it's
like a holy cow it's like a a bunker did you always sneak a
peek or did you manage to resist oh I snuck a peek so in my
right ear I remember asking mom once about where Walter had
gone you think he went down here she said after Barbara died
he got his far away as he could.
Oh, it is.
Like a...
Alvino!
Extra crispy!
You think the...
Pea soup?
Oh, I would die.
I'm already dead.
Just kill me again.
I think there's a pattern in all these stories.
Grape jelly.
You think all these are still good?
Peanut butter?
Tomato ketchup as opposed to...
tasty beans sweetie crisps I think it's that none of us has
gotten very far
it's pretty eerie down here Walter
just looking around
aww oh
that's cool I guess it's oh I guess it's nice too though
wait I don't want to do that yeah we'll go to him first
March 2005 yeah it's a painting goodbye everyone I can't
believe I've been down here for 30 years
on that first day after the shaking started I didn't think I
survived
I was never interested in looking, but found out later that
my mom would wrap some presents in foil like leftovers and
hide them in the freezer?
That's genius!
Which way do I?
Oh, there we go.
But after a few days, I settled into a routine.
Oh my god.
This one I have to do with my mouse.
It won't let me do with the arrow keys.
That's what kept me sane.
Having a schedule.
Living for today.
What are these, Peaches?
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches.
I love you.
No, you can just do anything.
No, our little ship.
No, please, God, don't make me do it again.
even a monster oh if i just like twirl my mouse around it's
way faster almost friendly
he's just gobbling him whole everything just yeah we figured
out the tech oh whatever that thing was it was gone maybe
you got tired of waiting what was the thing or maybe i just
got tired of being afraid is it does it coincide when
somebody died the date there's so many dates and names you
remember it's been a week now the longest in 30 years i'm
done waiting yeah i have to leave well i still can why don't
you Because he blocked it.
Good job, Walter.
He got them jiggly farms up in the bed.
When you're in a pinch, it's midnight.
You need a jiggly farm's midnight snack.
I get it, buddy.
We've all been there.
Sorry to tell you, dude, but weeks have always been seven
days.
More cereal.
He's got his gunpla.
Cereal gunpla.
Cracking the curse?
I need that.
Exorcism.
Warding away spirits.
Wait a second.
The Finch curse.
Evil unleashed.
Echoes from afar.
Wait a second.
I know it's out there somewhere.
My man loves his alvinos.
Whatever killed Barbara.
And Molly.
And Calvin.
This is just gonna break it apart?
What is this?
Don't tell me that's a toilet.
Oh, it's the garbage.
It could be both.
No, he had a toilet.
He had a toilet.
Do you think if he goes to the bathroom, it messes with
the...
Maybe this is all a mistake.
The water pressure of the main house.
Okay.
but I need to stop living the same day even if it kills me
for 30 years living the same day whatever's out there I want
you to know I'm ready for it I feel his voice does not match
how he looked I'm going to appreciate all of it especially
the food especially the food maybe he is a young guy but
it's just hard to tell because he had a big old beard.
I don't mind if I only have a year left.
Wait, why do you think that?
Or a month.
Oh.
Or a single week.
Or a day.
Or a second.
I'd be happy with one new day.
No.
I can already imagine the sun on my face.
Oh!
Oh, he thinks he's doomed because of the family curse.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Walter died when I was six.
I can't believe my mom never told me he was down here
That guy We don't talk about Walter being in the In the
walls Could we turn off the radio?
I'm sure my mom was trying to protect me
Oh, oops, my bad I accidentally clicked out of it One new
day Oh Walta, put your cans away, Walta.
I'm not eating peaches with you today, Walta.
He literally...
He literally went outside once.
Maybe she was afraid I'd end up like Walta.
Went outside once and died.
But if she never told me about an uncle under the house...
What else?
I can only imagine what else she was hiding.
Yeah, exactly.
I don't want to make the same mistakes she made.
I love when sometimes I'm looking...
at something and the game's like, no, no.
It feels like it feels like it's physically grabbing my head
and like pulling it into another direction.
I want to look at the garbage.
Fine.
Trying to bury something that's still alive.
Sorry, I know this game is serious.
I'm just trying to lighten it a little bit so it's not so
heavy for all of us, you know?
Or maybe two.
Two?
Only Walter, I'd be tubers.
I thought it was time I heard the stories for myself.
And found out what happened to everyone else.
But now I'm worried the stories themselves might be the
problem.
Maybe we believed so much in a family curse.
Yeah.
We made it real.
Right.
What's that over there?
Cool.
Wait, so how long has this leg been here then?
If the guy died by train.
Unless it was like a...
You know, maybe he died somewhere else.
But...
But there is a train track here.
Train was a metaphor.
Yeah, I guess so.
Cute.
Look, right?
Ah, I see it, I see it.
What's that red light?
I thought we were out like truly in the middle of nowhere,
but there's just...
There's stuff over there.
And there's chairs in the trees?
Totally.
Normal behavior.
I don't know if I should even be writing this.
maybe it'd be better if all this just died with me no oh
that's freaking I guess it's solar powered so it still works
but I thought you should know about your family are we
pregnant
and the history you're a part of look down
wait she has like a ring on so she was married or maybe
that's a family ring she hinted at something earlier too and
I was thinking oh maybe we're pregnant
regante but to be honest I feel as lost as you probably do
right now
I think the people in these stories believed them for what
that worth yeah I think so too I think they very much
believe them I want to go to the island with the red light
what's
out there it calls me no one knows well you can see the
other side it's
awesome to see you playing my favorite game yeah I'm really
enjoying it so far.
It kind of feels...
It kind of feels like watching a movie.
Have that history of imagination and stubbornness and
madness.
It's like walking the simulator.
Any of it seems possible.
It's kind of nice sometimes.
I don't have to do anything.
I just have to click sometimes and walk forward.
It's pretty nice.
Trash.
surrounded by death for so long, we've just gotten used to
it.
What's that?
Oh, a lamp.
What kind of family finishes building a cemetery before
starting the house?
Yeah, that's kind of crazy.
Oh my gosh, there it is.
It's embarrassing for me to admit this, but...
What?
The pet cemetery may be more uncomfortable than the human
one.
Oh, no, there's...
Three of the gerbils are mine, and...
Two had been my fault.
No, gerbils are just like that.
They really are.
They're just like that.
There they are.
Zerpy, lurpy, furpy, chirpy, burpy.
Derpy and Derpy Jr. Oh.
Oh.
A frog.
We don't know his name.
Oh.
She had a dog named Shadow.
Aww.
Sven built the house, but it was Edie who designed the
cemetery.
Oh my gosh.
There's just a little hole.
Wait, that's so cute!
Oh my gosh, that's so stinking cute.
Shadow the dog, she was a black lab.
I've never heard of a gerbil that didn't die in a metal way.
Right!
But it's also kind of awesome when you find gerbils that are
really old.
They're kind of fun.
Edie Finch.
Sven Finch.
Calvin Finch.
Molly Finch.
Oh, she's like her little cat.
Hmm.
I'm sure Odin's monument has been.
I'd been Edie's idea.
My mom was always trying to move on.
But for Edie, the past never went away.
I was going to say, what about, like, Edie's mom and dad and
everything, too?
He's like my home!
She could see it poking out of the water at low tide.
That's the home!
No stinking way.
That's what it is.
Edie said she dreamed about the old house every night
That's awesome
Where do I go from here though?
Uh, hold on, let me look around a bit more maybe Nope I have
one chance Further down?
Is there a way to- I don't think there is a further down
I was thinking I may be looking at that but up
then right oh here okay okay wait yes yes we didn't go this
way but the older I get the more I can see where my mom was
coming from
gory her dad had been pretty strict but it wasn't enough to
save her brothers she was just trying to do better oh my
gosh Okay, hold on.
I'm going to look at it.
So, it starts with Odin.
Sven and Edie are Odin's...
Uh, well, Edie is Odin's, uh...
What's the word?
Daughter.
They...
This is such a bizarre family tree.
The way they drew it does not make sense.
Yeah, daughter.
son-in-law.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They have Sam, Calvin, Barbara, Molly.
Walter?
Where does Kay come from?
Wait, no.
Sam.
Sam stays alive.
I guess he is with Kay.
Kay and Sam have Gus Gregory Dawn.
Dawn goes with Sanjay.
And they have Lewis, Milton, Edith.
Yeah, everything in blue is like the Finch family proper.
And then the little, like in black leaves are the people
that marry in, it seems.
Think you got it?
Okay, okay.
There's so many names.
Holy cow.
Okay, hold on.
So Sam is, okay.
He's one of their, he's one of their sons.
Okay.
And so, Gus and Gregory are the two that are Dawn's
brothers.
Okay.
Yeah, Sam is the twin of Calvin.
Yes, yes, yes.
She lost two of her brothers, just like I did.
why she tried so hard to protect us oh oh yeah there's her
dad and milton a guy the brother that went missing lewis we
don't know about yet it seems we never found milton's body
so my mom insisted we were putting up a monument not a
tombstone oh there's
so many things i wish i could ask my mom now this is what
she wanted all along for me to come back someday and find
everything out for myself oh
I'm stuck we're going we're trusting this we're thinking
that this is safe and okay that's fine I mean what else what
do we got to lose huh looking back on it now
If she told me there was going to be so much climbing, I
never would have come when I was 22 weeks pregnant.
You're pregnant!
Oh my god!
Okay, you got this?
Jump?
Uh, maybe don't go on the glass?
I never met Grandpa Sam, but I think he and my mom had a lot
in common.
works in this place they were both pretty intense where oh
is this Sam's room oh yeah it must be because he yeah all
the photography Sam spent his life shooting photos but mom
said he got nervous being in front of the camera and also
shooting animals and people baby shooting everything this
guy can't Stop shooting!
Dang!
It's like five to six months pregnant, right?
Oh my gosh.
I don't understand why they talk in months.
Why are they like, yeah, my baby is 300 months old.
I don't know what that is.
Once it gets to a year old, why can't we just say a year and
five months?
That ain't a baby.
300 months is 25 years old.
Quinto is 228 months old forever.
I don't even reach 300 months.
I just set a number.
And you know what?
I said that and in my brain, I was like, what is that?
Three?
I'm crying.
Man.
Did you mean weeks?
No.
Okay.
Look at that guy.
My name's Sam.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
What else is in here?
Instead of hiding from death, Sam seemed to go out of his
way to meet it.
He got a little feet on his wall.
Not the cat.
Okay, that I'm not okay with.
I mean, I don't like taxidermy in general, but, you know.
Not the cat.
But I kind of want to get my cat taxidermied.
I want to pet him all the time.
He's so soft.
It's like the most...
Oh, that's a Facebook profile picture if I've ever...
What the hell?
If I've ever seen one.
Dawn, I promise.
You'll never forget this weekend.
Yes, sir.
These memories are going to last a lifetime.
Perfect.
Oh.
It's going to rain the whole weekend, isn't it?
I will never forget this weekend, Dad.
Oh, that's our mom.
Okay, got it.
I'm going to take some pictures, okay?
Okay.
Just be careful.
The camera's older than you are.
Does he want the bird?
Aw.
Well, we've taken pictures of.
You're right, Dad.
It's starting to clear up.
Still freezing, though.
Mmm.
Definitely should not have drunk all that coffee.
peeing oh hey that's the keeper oh i don't know why i take a
picture of you i don't know about that i'm just saying i'm
not always gonna be here don you'll need to remember this
stuff if you want to survive i'll be fine dad you know who
else thought he was gonna be fine who some guy who died don
i'm being serious i know dad you're always serious doesn't
being out here make you want to chill out to tell you the
truth i haven't been out here in 20 years whoa fish
that's a good fish what are that last time i was with my
brother cali dad good eyes dawn
cool oh wait he's he got interrupted though he was talking
about his brother wait i didn't i didn't click anything it
just interrupted him himself dad I just breathe turn off
your imagination focus on your target what's the target
there is nothing there oh my god sniper wolf in the making
let me get behind you
don't you don't have to do anything but if you want to
survive you'll need to be strong
That's quiet.
Um, quiet has brown hair and I quite very clearly see a
blondie right in front of me.
Like sniper wolf, okay?
Great shot, Don.
She just dies it.
Oh my god!
My daughter's crying, let me take a selfie?
No way!
Oh my- I'm proud of you, Don.
Always remember that, okay?
Oh, oh.
Sorry Don, just gotta reset the timer.
Oh, there's a timer!
Run run run run
Dad it's twitching.
I think it's totally normal.
Don just focus on the camera try not to think about dad Is
that how he dies?
Oh My god, that's the one I wish most that my mom had told
me Holy cow Holy dear that's totally normal he says and
the fact that there's a photo of it how traumatic oh my gosh
that's so messed up guessing the next part is over here's no
airline ticket though well that sounded like something
moving
It was right next to me.
Oh, I missed it.
Oh, thank you.
I missed it.
I did miss it.
He was twitching.
After Sam died, my mom and Edie got really close.
They'd both lost a lot.
Yeah, Edie.
Holy cow.
Wow.
Gregory.
Wait, Gregory does have a room.
He doesn't just This exists in a bathroom.
Whoa.
Where is this?
Wow, oh my gosh, that view.
Baby Gregory.
What is his story gonna be?
Googaga.
Googoo.
I can't imagine my mom ever writing poetry and yet...
Poem for Gus.
Sorry.
Not the emergency evacuation plan For this house House rules
No playing outside without permission No answering doors for
strangers And no answering door for strangers No messes
after dark All chores before dark Respect others That seems
pretty fair That seems pretty fair I'd say Race flag 730 a
.m.
Breakfast 8 a.m.
Quiet time 11 p.m.
Duty is dawn Sweep and trash Gus Mop mo yard Greg be a baby
Minto be a baby Rays flag They seem pretty They seem like
Yeah like the American flag They probably have like a
Probably because Seems the dad was in the military So
They're very patriotic Goo goo gaga Routine jump rope 100%
Oh 100 times Jumping jacks 150 times.
Push-ups 100 times.
They're trying to become one punch man over here.
Crunches 100 times.
Run to mailbox and back.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Yeah, Saitama routine.
Wait, this is awesome!
Oh my gosh, I would have killed for this.
I used to love rock climbing like this.
Oh, I would have...
Oh, I would have been so excited.
Wow, this house owns.
It's kind of awesome.
It's terrifying and awesome at the same time.
I'm sold.
Climbing wall.
Yeah!
Baby bubble bonanza.
Divorce?
Not the baby.
Lawsuit has been filed against you.
You have 20 calendar days after this summons is served on
you to file a written response.
Dear Kay, do you remember the way Gregory used to laugh when
he thought he was alone?
Like, something funny was happening, but only he could see
it.
We're going to witness the baby death?
The ducky is staring at me.
It isn't graphic or anything.
They haven't been so far, so I wasn't going to imagine that
this one would be too...
Imagine if they're just like, okay, here comes the baby.
I already I already know what's going to happen because of
where we are at I fear
Oh I don't want to do it
What if the ducky is Medusa and we are reduced we are turned
to stone And that's why we're not moving It's my fault I
know why but you know
I guess we have to to get through it.
Oh, I don't want to, though.
Oh.
I think he saw things the rest of us don't.
Oh, I don't like when kids look in the corner.
They're staring at me, usually.
I don't like that.
Oh!
How high can he go?
Oh, Gregory, it's time to...
Uh-oh.
Hold on, sweetie.
No, no.
Hello?
Oh, mama, no, mama!
Sam, I told you I don't want to talk right now.
I wonder what he saw.
What his world was like.
Oh, look how cute they are.
Where could them go?
Lost in his imagination.
Oh,
my God.
All the friends come in.
Whatever it was, he saw.
This is so cute, though, at the same time.
Whoa!
Oh, I get away from the handle.
.
The whale is watching.
This doesn't seem like a good idea.
Knock all those.
Knock it all in.
Oh my gosh, I'm so close.
Get it.
Oh my god.
I thought I had it.
You said the toys would be fun in the bath before.
I did say that, didn't I?
Oh my god, and they're here.
Maybe I am the baby.
Kinto duties.
Gregory's name into the bathtub.
I got an achievement for it.
Maybe I am the baby.
Knock this off.
Unplug the tub.
I don't... Am I supposed to do this?
Okay.
Oh my god, it'd be so morbid if I turned on the water.
Where am I supposed to go though?
Can I get to the whale?
Oh, I'm on the whale.
You're made of happy.
Oh, my gosh.
Whale!
I'm flipping over.
Yeah!
Oh.
Boing.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, wait, one second.
What?
It's like platforming now?
If they really wanted to break your heart, they should have
done like the padadu and it would have been so sad.
Wait, hold on!
Let me up there!
They're like, oh, you can't get all the way up there, that's
fine.
I'll give you the...
I know how silly it sounds.
I got it!
Nice and saucy!
and clean come on about gregory i know you did everything
you could maybe if i hadn't called that night hold
on i don't want gregory to hear this
oh no i wish she could have told us about the world itself
Oh my god.
No, turn it off!
Turn it off!
There's so much I don't understand.
About everything.
Yeah, go get to the plug, get to the plug.
Get to the plug!
What
happened wasn't your fault.
Oh, I can go faster.
I can go faster.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh, oh.
I'm sure he's happy.
No!
And he'd want you to be happy too.
Good luck, Kay.
Love, Sam.
I think even for, like, toddlers i think it's like 30
seconds in a pool what's even crazier is like there's there
will be like like at parties and stuff you know everyone
will think that someone's watching the kids but it's usually
like oh because some there's so many people they'll think
but there's it can happen so fast like it can i've i've
heard so many stories it's like so crazy
babies can drown in two inches of water it's insane yeah
there's so many horror stories and like oh my gosh i i heard
one literally just the other day about like you know about
like uh it was like a family and they were in their kitchen
and no one heard the kid just slip out from the chair and
walk out the door and then go into the lake which first of
all what the heck kid what are you drawn to the lake for I'm
not trying to blame the kid obviously but it's just like oh
my gosh that's the first thing you do you have freedom and
you go to the lake it's so sad kids are stealthy they really
are they really are he yearns so sad
it's not you know something i can relate to but i mean i
can't imagine for a family just how devastating you know
like how could you even like be around the other person ever
again
adults can drown in two inches of water take drowning risks
seriously drowning is so scary be careful you guys hopefully
not ever
explains the well it seems like the divorce was coming
before then because he was calling her you know And she was
like, ah, don't call me.
Oh, wait.
Where was she getting it?
No.
She was like, stop calling me.
Or something.
Yeah, it was already happening.
They were separated and arguing on the phone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's so sad.
I guess, um...
I guess that was probably the quote on...
unquote easiest way they could have shown that scene
probably maybe that
was the worst one in the game i'm glad we got it over with
uh
i mean i knew that the baby i just don't want to like i
don't want to go back and die i mean i knew that the baby
past obviously but I don't want to like I didn't know what
to expect a later one feels worse to me really yes we'll see
hmm at least it was quick it was pretty quick yeah and it
was very cute like all things considered it was very cute
and I was having fun, being a little froggy, bouncing
around, so.
Look how funny the baby looks on the...
Honestly, I thought that too.
The portrait she drew makes him look demonic.
I think Edith...
I think...
Hopefully Edith is not an artiste.
In fact, I don't understand really why she's drawing
everybody.
Like he looks so...
I didn't want to say anything when she drew him because it
was right after but my first thought was just Edith.
Why are we sketching everybody?
Oh my goodness gracious.
At least it's not AI.
Edith picks up the pencil.
She'll get better.
Maybe.
She's just a hobbyist.
Yeah, most of them look pretty good.
I'd say.
Like, Barbara's looks good.
I'd say Walters looks good.
Sam's looks good.
Calvin is, like, whatever.
Odin's is okay.
Molly's is okay.
But Gregory.
Gregory got done so dirty.
She even drew herself so cute.
Oh.
Gregory.
All right.
Well, we have another one to get into also.
So let's check this one out too.
Gus with his cool mohawk.
And his...
Oh my god, he's a punk.
He's an actual...
He's an actual punk.
Oh, this is long.
A poem for Gus.
Who always said the wedding was a bad idea.
Our father never hit us kids.
At least not very hard.
Before the day my brother said regard that he'd be dead
before he'd see a wedding in our yard oh not yet
we oh my god i'm just disrupting the wedding crash into the
wedding party
where's the next part
This is why they yearn for childless weddings.
You're just gonna have some kid that's like...
How do I get this part?
Oh, do I have to flip it around?
Oh, I have to flip it around myself.
Okay.
My father made him come, of course, but Gus stood far apart.
Just flew his kite and bottled up the storm inside his
heart.
I can't collect these ones though.
Ah, so close.
I tried to talk him out of it, but though he'd never met
her, we don't need a stepmom, we're the words that I...
I now pronounce you, husband and wife.
Ah, boo!
He's an emo little kid.
When the time for photos came, Dad ordered him to come here.
Oh.
But Gus declined, and as a sign held up his middle finger,
Ah, yeah!
I don't want to be part of your photos!
This one's fun too.
I feel such childhood whimsy with all of these.
He disappeared and quickly went.
But all the humans did that day was go inside the tent.
Oh, they're gone.
Uh-oh.
It's not thunder, is it?
Meow!
Oh my god.
Katamari.
Rain came down in buckets then, but no one seemed afraid.
That nature might destroy the tent our dad had crudely made.
Oh, there's more.
Oh my god.
The thunder sounded much too close and full of angry power.
But all my father said to this was, Make the music louder.
Yeah, Benjamin Franklin time.
He's gonna get struck.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
Oh!
Yeah, duck down, duck down.
I wish that I could truly say I thought about you on that
day.
Out there on the beach alone.
Just you, the wind, the sea, and foam.
Oh!
But I didn't.
Until we found you.
It's kind of...
That's so, so morbid.
She never talked about him, but mom told me once if I was a
boy, they were going to name me Gus.
She was like, yeah, I didn't get, I don't care about you at
all.
Didn't think one thought about you the whole day.
Wow, okay.
You climbing up?
My mom moved up to the loft after her brothers died.
That's so sad.
At the time, it was as far away as she could get.
Now you know where those tree chairs were from.
No kidding, you're right!
Oh my gosh.
Religion was another thing my mom never talked about.
But I think it helped her a lot after her dad died.
She's in India, boo.
She spent a summer building.
My mom moved to India a week after graduation and got a job
teaching English.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, my bad.
What'd she say?
Fly to India!
I guess she became an English teacher over there.
Is that what it seemed like?
I, it, I, it, it, it, it, it happened on its own.
I didn't click anything.
I went to here.
I was just going to open it and then it happened.
Hmm.
And she met Sanjay.
I'm trying to see.
She's even got a phone up in here and everything.
High school.
Dawn Finch.
Wow.
Don't forget.
Visa application.
Background check.
Inter.
Some.
She's thinking for two.
Happens sometimes.
They're so detailed in this game.
with like every single little thing has something oh wait
that's not what i meant to do i have to climb back up sorry
guys uh well we got to try it oh interview i think you're
right can you imagine marrying into this family not knowing
the history seriously though
Lewis was born a year later Oh my god There's still Missing
posters up here
I don't trust this at all Oh my gosh This place is so Like
Hastily When my dad died I don't think mom knew where else
to go I'm sure Edie was happy to have her back Oh my gosh Oh
my gosh And to see kids in the house again.
And then they all die!
Oh!
Mom!
I'm in the game!
Oh my god!
It's like it's my grave!
Wow!
I'm in the game!
The house had to get a little bigger, but Edie was used to
that.
Just keep building up, baby.
God, it really does feel like the Winchester mansion.
And for a while, things were good.
Almost normal.
Whoa.
Our family history.
Fact or fiction?
Flip one.
You could say anything, and I would believe it, about this
family.
Wait a second.
You died?
I need this.
Wait, I need this.
Multiplication tape.
Yeah, the fire code.
Oh, sorry.
Fire code in this place goes crazy.
I could not learn with that buzzing sound.
Put it in last.
Odin.
The curse!
Oh my gosh.
Hello kids, let me teach you about the curse of our family.
The beginning of the end was Milton's 10th birthday.
When Edie gave him a castle.
Oh, it's sealed.
After Milton disappeared, the only thing he left behind was
a room full of paintings.
Wait, is there anything over here?
It's so pretty here, though.
He's an artiste.
Does this turn into a door?
Whoa.
It's cool.
What is this?
Oh, he's like an architect.
Not an architect, but you know.
Maybe he wanted to be one.
Follow the gamer paint!
Let's follow the gamer paint!
It's made for me!
holy blueprints oh my gosh wait he even has the crown and
everything you're so right can you imagine being like nine
years old and you have this observatory we haven't even gone
up there have we you have this like awesome observatory and
like a room where you can like pulley yourself up and ever
like this is this would be the greatest ever What the hell
is that?
Extra, extra.
American newspaper.
Baby.
Milton Finch in the magic paintbrush.
Oh.
Oh,
he's drawing.
Oh, my gosh.
Whoa.
Flipbook Inception.
Oh, the door works.
The door works.
This game go hard.
I love the different medium.
Wait.
I was four when Milton disappeared.
I'm dirty too.
Milton went into the door.
mom spent months searching for my brother then she sealed
the doors
whatever milton had found in the house mom didn't want it
getting out
oh there's an upstairs oh my gosh the game is pretty good
about leading you places obviously i was mom definitely
blamed edie but i think lewis blamed himself are so busy
looking at this you don't notice the staircase behind you
it's kind of cool mat flow design is great after he
graduated he just spent more and more time in his room until
mom got him a job at the cannery the cannery with the tuna
he didn't needed a caretaker after my mom left for india we
hired a maid to help take care of her at the house mint was
her name Maid Min didn't do much cleaning, but was fond of
singing.
She passed an audition and left for the East.
Haven't seen her since.
Thank you so much for the pink.
Thank you.
Lewis.
Everyone always told me to stay out of Lewis's room.
Except Lewis.
I got an achievement for looking through all the peoples.
Whoa.
Wait.
What was...
Is that a drug?
Is that?
Is this broken?
Yes.
Because I don't know how she trusts this place, man.
Like, who built this to begin with, even?
What did other people think of the town, I wonder?
This reminds me, though, of...
where my sister lives truly actually I think she moved I
think she moved but she lived in this place and she would
have like it was like a big a big big property and no like
these little tree house looking places the people that she
bought it from they've made stuff that looks like this and
they would do like rituals on the property my sister bought
it so that she could keep doing rituals on the property i
think she just got i think she just sold it recently
louis's room smelled very very familiar that part of him
lived on the stank that's the worst can you imagine louis
stunk so bad that his His room still smelled like him.
That's terrible.
Lewis and I spent a lot of time playing games together, but
he was surprisingly bad at them.
He died a lot.
Oh, I...
I...
Yeah.
He was so proud of being Indian.
I think for him, it was a way to be something other than
just a Finch.
Whoa.
Yeah, I thought it was just like, he died.
That's what I thought.
My guy's a gamer.
Oh, what do we have in here?
Oliver Twist!
Oh, he watches the same thing.
Like, conspiracy now.
And their wedding for some reason.
Oh, well.
Oh, my guy's a gamer.
He's got figures and everything.
All right, let's check it out.
Dear Mrs. Finch, as Lewis's psychiatrist, I can understand
your desire for an explanation.
As I see it, the trouble began in January, shortly after we
convinced your son to seek treatment for substance abuse.
Ooh!
Newly sober, I believe Lewis first noticed the monotony of
his daily life.
Oh, gosh.
He kept working at the cannery.
But he withdrew part of himself.
It looks like the arm from Poppy's playtime.
In our sessions, I saw the same behavior.
At least...
His mind began to...
At least I'm blocking the fish getting decapitated.
them began to I
began to what
is that I can't even grab it
wonder oh he's a little guy I asked him to describe it he
said he started to
Imagining a labyrinth.
I'm doing my job, I'm doing my job.
I'm still being a good employee.
He'd feel his way about.
Yeah.
I'm so concentrated right now.
Something moved.
And toads?
Ooh.
You can tell when I'm, like, getting confused, like, I'm
grabbing it and I'll make him go this way, you know?
And things that have not names.
He knew it was all in his head.
Oh, freaky.
But he took it very seriously.
I had hoped he'd find himself.
I'm so good at doing my job.
But he found something more.
Whoa!
Can I just stop doing my job?
I worried about him then.
Daydreaming at the cannery.
Yeah, you probably want to concentrate on this kind of joke.
I spoke with his boss.
But he said Lewis had become a model employee.
Methodical.
Tireless.
Focus.
Yeah, because that's all he's not even thinking about it.
He's just doing the motions.
Like a whole new Lewis.
I'm gonna let the fish see what happens if I don't...
So I let him go on.
Touch the fish.
Whoa, I even encouraged him.
It's getting bigger.
Hey, you're... I mean, I'm playing my game.
Get out of the way, fish.
It seemed very promising at first.
He told me he'd made a new friend.
Ooh, the fish kind of get in the way too, though.
On the edge of a city he named Louis Topia.
Louis Topia.
Do I have to cut off the fish?
Ah!
Crazy.
Oh, that's so cool!
He built the city up slowly, brick by brick.
Thank you, thank you, Bard.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm home.
I'm here.
Then he made musicians.
Yes, yes, I'm home.
You're great leaders here.
And songs for them to play.
He talked about starting a band.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
And he was always humming something.
The little people dancing are so cute.
every day his imagination grew stronger this is actually he
no longer spoke at the cannery
help this way but his chopping was as reliable as ever you
gotta be careful of your hand yeah at all the cheering
crowds even the stones under his We're fake.
We're all in his imagination.
So he could do whatever he wished.
Whoa.
He held an election for men.
When he is an election, if you're...
And he won.
Really?
Haha.
They begged him to stay, but his mind was already wandering.
Oh.
It became a game for him.
Oh, oh.
Hey, get out of the way, I'm playing my game.
Lewis-topia.
No more.
Can I conquer this city?
New Lewisville.
I think there's only two fish at a time.
St. Louis.
He started drifting away from our reality.
These kids in there are video games.
Until one day he forgot to go home from the cannery.
Oh, that's not good.
Even as his mother pleaded with him, part of Lewis kept
sailing on.
He's just doing it.
Oh, we're just...
He's so into the game in his brain.
In Lewisburg, he heard rumors of a...
Uh...
Oh, we can have a handsome queen?
Or a beautiful prince.
I want the handsome queen, though.
Why is she handsome?
Yeah.
I want to know what a handsome queen is like.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Cool.
Hey, get out of the way, fish.
That's my handsome queen here on top.
For...
Sinister serpents.
Nice.
Oh my gosh, it's a choose your own adventure.
Woo!
I'm getting sucked into the brain game.
The sound of her.
Uh...
Electric sitar Whoa
Oops, I missed one.
Wait, go through.
No!
I missed it.
Turn around.
I missed.
Oh, dang it.
His chase led him to a golden palace east of the sun and
west of the moon.
Dang it.
Whoa.
Even then, his logic remained sound.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Oh, it's completely taken over.
Oh my god.
Are we gonna get our hand chopped off?
He knew the world was all in his imagination.
There's too many fish!
But he can't stop.
He can't stop thinking about it.
Otherwise, all you think about is fish.
Well, we're in a totally different game.
But he's so proud of having created it.
Ugh!
In his own eyes, he becomes...
something greater than a king whoa hey
get out of the way fish for someone who'd never known
success get down mr.
president I'm protecting you from the fish it's the little
that the real Lewis was not the one chopping salmon but the
one climbing the steps of a golden palace oh yeah
my imagination is as real as my body he told me what do we
look like nice it was hard to argue with him what's the
point of having a giant door up here oh our arm is gone oh
oh oh this is where we are but we think we're in the golden
palace this is where we really are though wait we finally
stopped the fish this is me this is my locker oh they love
chinese food wait no my my switch i began to forget the
world we know
i think it pained him to remember lewis the cannery worker i
get it Wait, are they just dropping...
Are these alive fish or...
Dead fish?
That's him doing the job!
2DS, yeah, 2DS.
He began to despise the man with a royal contempt.
He's got his football jersey on.
But you're not even doing anything anymore!
Do I go up?
I still thought I could save him.
Even after he said he was being crowned king over all the
lands of Wanda.
The palace would be packed with his companions.
But he should have...
become like a game dev or something he should have like made
his own game from including the wise Calico who'd insisted
on advising him you know sir
sir his queen waited holding his crown my hand oh oh oh
there was only one thing left to do oh Oh,
um, sir, I think they're, they're, they're, they're tricking
you.
I think they're, this is a bamboozle.
I think anybody would realize.
I think anybody would see, that's not how you put on a
crown.
I think.
The queen is sure as handsome.
Bend down his head.
And the rest I think you know.
Mrs. Finch, your son was a kind man who will be missed by
all of us who knew him.
My brother was really cool.
I wish you could have met him.
Aww.
Oh my god.
How did the doctor not pick up on this?
How did the doctor...
I feel like she...
Oh my god.
Not the hat having like...
The, the, the, what's it called?
The tuna blood stains on it.
Cigars.
Sure, that's from the fish.
I sure hope so.
Let's just, let's just, let's just.
I'm back from Lewis's funeral.
My mom told me to start packing.
She waited until the day before we left to tell Edie.
I'm not sure if she wanted to make it easier or harder.
Hmm.
Where do you go?
Oh my sweet stayed There's so many
It's implied he committed forever sleep or fell asleep on
his day From his daydream at work onto the bell I think yeah
I wouldn't I mean I don't think it makes it any easier but I
feel like Fell asleep Feels a little nicer than Than
committed forever sleep
We feel asleep.
But I understand why we left.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
That's the good...
Oh.
That's the good stuff.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Turn it up, baby.
Oh, come on.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's the good stuff.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Give me more peanuts.
Oh.
Just a little more.
Okay.
The one-finch kitchen.
But why did they leave in such like a hurry is my thing?
Like they took nothing.
They left everything.
Is it because it was like a too painful of a memory?
My mom ended up leaving everything behind.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Just desperate to get away from the home, I guess, maybe.
Disaster relief.
Oh.
Whoa.
To teach and to learn.
Orca's publishing.
It really is full of Yuri.
What happened that night had been coming for a long time.
Maybe it should have come sooner.
My room.
But it had to end one way or another.
Oh, so cute.
Oh my gosh.
All that's left now was to tell you about that last night.
Yeah, he passed away too, but we don't quite know how.
How Papa passed away.
This room is so cute.
Why are there so many unmarked books?
But they're so aesthetically pleasing.
I don't mind.
Oh wow, that's so cool!
She made the house like with paper mache.
Suddenly, are we crawling again?
Yeah, why are we doing that?
I don't think it's that low of a ceiling.
Little guys, she loves making little guys, little figures.
These ones are creepy though.
I think you missed Dawn's death in her room.
Did I?
She's 10 feet tall.
Oh, I didn't.
I was gonna say, it's really hard to miss stuff in this
game, no?
I didn't miss anything.
Okay, thank you guys.
It was a one guy.
Thank you!
Yeah, I feel like it's really...
The game is so linear.
I don't know how you could miss anything, to be honest.
Edith Finch That whole last day Edie just watched his pack
and didn't say a word She's leaving her whole house Until
supper when she raised her glass and said To our final night
together And all our final nights apart Grandma, you know
what I said about alcohol Some of your medications are very
specific I left a present for you in the hallway Why don't
you go open it the grown-ups have to argue now I'm sorry
you're right we're all leaving tomorrow let's just enjoy I'm
not leaving Edith you're excused she's she eating with a
single chopstick the
power had been shut off that morning but Edie always had
plenty of candles that seems really dangerous when my mom
said of the library.
I don't think she knew about the other entrance.
Other end?
Here.
Or that Edie had a key to it.
Whoa.
Yeah, especially in this house, on top of all these books.
It's no wonder the place didn't catch on fire.
Unless it's about to somehow.
That thing you're afraid of isn't going to end when you
leave the house.
I don't blame the mom, honestly.
We'll have the nursing home send a van for you in the
morning.
Mimi, hi!
Oh, this game is kind of sad.
History of the Finches.
Dear Edith, there's so many stories I wish I could tell you,
but there's only time for one.
This is about what happened on the night you were born.
There's more!
That night, the tide went way, way out.
Oh my gosh.
I mean, I guess there are still people in our journal that
we haven't written about, but holy cow.
Is someone going to the...
It was the first and last time I ever saw the old house
aground.
Yeah, I was going to say, is someone going to the house?
There's been an earthquake out in the middle of the ocean.
Oh, so there's just going to be a tsunami.
The lowest tide in a thousand years.
But when the water pulls back, that's not good!
God, it smells awful.
You know, I've seen that house every day of my life.
Oh, gosh.
But I never thought I'd go back to it.
When the fog roared in, I lost my way.
Oh, my God!
Just look for the red light.
Uh, oh.
I got turned around.
No, I was definitely going straight towards it.
Oh, my gosh.
Silent Hill moment.
Uh.
For a while, I wondered.
Yeah, Grandma's got the plot armor.
I started seeing things.
No, I think that guy might actually be there.
Or he senses that there's grave danger.
Things I'd forgotten had ever existed.
Where are you talking?
Oh, here.
What kind of things?
But when I saw them, they felt like old friends.
Oh, your old bed for him.
Would you even remember?
That night, a lot of things came back to me.
Whoa.
Would you even remember?
Well, some of these things I probably would remember, like
the stove.
Maybe certain chairs.
Oh, my God, the toilet.
Oh.
Oh, I'd know that toilet from anywhere.
Or maybe I came back to them.
Oh my gosh, the gate is all set up.
Like, it was just...
It's like just a normal old house.
That's crazy.
Things I can't explain, but that I need you to try.
Edith, what are you doing in here?
It's mine.
Edith!
Mom, you're gonna rip it, let go!
Oh!
I kicked and screamed, but mom dragged me to the car.
I never saw Great Grandma Edie again.
Grandma!
The next morning, the van came to pick her up, but she was
already gone.
Where'd she go?
After that, we moved around a lot.
We both tried to make the best of it.
A few years went by.
My mom didn't like to talk about it, but she started getting
sick a lot.
The rest happened pretty quickly.
She got better for a while, and then she didn't.
And then I was alone.
The last Finch left alive.
That's crazy.
Until I found out about you.
I'm still not sure what to tell you about all this.
Am I the baby?
If we lived forever, maybe we'd have time to understand
things.
But as it is, I think the best we can do is try to open our
eyes.
I think I'm the baby and the woman.
home right now.
I appreciate how strange and brief all of this is.
Oh my god.
I'm being bored.
I'm being born.
Everybody.
This is not a drill.
I think I'm being birthed.
Wait.
Oh my god.
But now I hope you'll never see it.
I'm being reincarnated at this very moment.
I just want to meet you and tell you all these stories
myself.
I'm going in!
I guess if you're reading this now.
Things didn't work out that way.
Wait, what happened?
This is where your story begins.
I'm sorry I won't be there to see it.
It's a lot to ask, but I don't want you to be sad that I'm
gone.
I want you to be amazed that any of us ever had a chance to
be here at all.
Good luck.
Good luck!
That's rich.
she she died in childbirth what so
were they cursed or oh my god oh the end of everything
finish all stories the baby pictures are so cute it's for us
to decide i guess you know was some of it them kind of
getting the idea i've heard of stuff like that before though
where people will be like my family is cursed and they get
it so in their head that their family is cursed that like
they're just like they're that they like i don't know it's
not that they bring the misfortune upon themselves but like
they manifest it in a way yeah kind of
because even like um who was it not lewis um Not Milton.
The guy that was living under the house.
He was living under there because he was paranoid of the
curse.
You know, stuff like that.
Walter.
Thank you.
See Joanne's name in the ending credits.
Wait, I got an achievement.
Who's Joanne?
I was like, I thought it...
I thought...
It starts with a W.
Oh my gosh.
flip it around Walter Witch I thought the way they conveyed
each story and how each one was done in such a different way
was really neat they were so it was so engaging seeing like
each story was really kind of fun
just being told throughout time that your family is cursed
kind of gets to you I feel doesn't help with how you're
raised yeah that's Fair.
But also, like, all they...
It all just was one thing.
They, they, like, came to the island?
Oh, my God.
Holy Melissa.
They came to the island and then they were like...
We're cursed, I guess.
I'm pretty sure physics and poor decision making in them.
Peaches.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches.
Some of them, though, like, Barbara is...
That was her name, right, Barbara?
That one was confusing.
Why did she pass away?
How did she die?
You believe the curse enough that you bring the misfortune
and continued the cycle.
Ah.
Yeah, Barbara the Child Star.
Yeah, that one was...
That one was strange.
That one kid just slingshot at himself.
I...
But I mean, some of them did seem like, I mean, there was
just a lot of accidents, so I kind of also get it where it's
like...
There's so many accidents.
At what point, how many accidents does it make... Does it
have... Wait, how many accidents have to happen before it's
like a pattern?
You know what I mean?
Some of them were weird deaths.
Yeah, they were, they were, right?
They were like strange accidents.
I can't believe one of them.
Straight up got eaten.
The end.
Aww, their little team is so cute.
Well, replay a story option is now available.
Select Edith to play from the beginning.
Oh, I could just go through anybody that I wanted.
Interesting.
Oh, there's Edie too.
We never saw her draw Edie or Dawn.
sense because it was like endgame.
Edith's son has a cast on his arm.
The cycle might still be going.
Wait, no way!
At the very end?
Milton looks like Doug funny.
I thought he looked familiar but I couldn't place it.
I
I think, oh, it's kind of frustrating that we get no answers
on Milton, but at the same time...
At the same time, sometimes that's just what happens.
Sometimes you never know, you know.
It's not satisfying at all.
Milton's in another game.
Wait, what?
Played the unfinished swan by the same devs.
I was about to say, what if he ran away from home because he
was just like, Like, screw this curse.
I'm going to go make my own life.
Is it possible to sneak into the library via the secret
entrance?
I don't think the game will let you.
The game is extremely linear.
It only lets you do things when you can, I think.
The unfinished swan is told a lot like Molly or Gregory
stories.
Good to know.
Thank you for the warning.
Hmm.
I don't know what to expect.
This was just so depressing.
This was just so sad.
It was so fascinating and also so depressing.
Kind of like a morbid curiosity, I feel.
I feel like Edith has it too, where it's like a morbid
curiosity of wanting to know how her family died and what's
going on you know what i mean i
think i realized what happened to melt and look up the devs
other games yeah that's what people were saying such
a good game but some of it does get to you yeah i didn't
expect it to be so sad like it was just that's the whole
thing the game is just tragedy after tragedy but you know we
can appreciate these kinds of story-tellings too.
I suppose.
Hmm.
Another game for the list, yeah?
Not much mystery, really.
Yeah!
I thought there would be a little more like of a...
It was...
I don't know.
Like, I was so curious why they, like, up and left such in a
hurry in the very beginning.
I was like, but why did they just pick up and leave?
But then, it was just kind of like the mom being like...
No, I don't want to be here anymore and just left, you know?
Thank you for playing this game, I always wanted to
experience it.
Yeah, of course, of course.
Yeah, they had a fight and mom was just like, see ya.
And then Grandma left.
You have to wonder.
Also, it's just like the mom left, but...
To protect Edith, right?
But was Edith even really protected?
Like...
The mom still died, and Edith still died.
What good did it do?
Grandma is the killer.
Grandma's been secretly putting like hallucinogenics and or
rat poisoning.
Small traces in the food.
The hallucinogenics is...
Definitely a gas.
A gas.
Gas leak would like really explain a lot.
But this house is nuts, though.
You just go to a different part of the house.
Also, there was like that...
I guess we went to the upstairs a different way.
Yeah, there was like the upstairs that was locked.
Oh my gosh, yes, not a gas leak.
Black mold infestation.
That will also make you go crazy.
It will.
Oh my god.
as simple as that what you wait that would be like such good
like environmental storytelling if like she never talked
about it but if there would be like mold on like you would
just notice kind of like i mean look there was just so much
food left out that's not black mold but come on from all the
books like becoming moldy and stuff
bad decisions.
Yeah, I mean, that doesn't...
I mean, I don't know.
Some of it, I guess it does explain to him.
You know, Molly would be negligence.
Barbara is just a complete mystery.
Calvin?
How did Calvin die again?
Oh, that probably was bad decisions.
Sam was bad decision.
Walter Walter, the guy just stepped outside, no?
Gregory was obviously negligence.
Gus, I think, was half negligence, half bad decision.
I think the point was that bad circumstances at home tend to
follow you for life.
Like a generational...
Who breaks the curse?
Who breaks the generational trauma, you know?
Someone has to.
Is it just like Edith tried, maybe?
I don't know, but she went back home.
I don't think she ever really got over it.
Which I'm not, like, blaming her.
But...
She was parkouring.
With the baby.
She was parkouring with the baby.
Milton, Milton, we don't know.
Lewis was...
even know just mental two player parkour the baby was was
what's the word the baby was adding was keeping her stable
that's the word preg core
there's a meta story of Milton and the unfinished swan but I
do like to think Milton just pieced out and ran away from
this house of crazy I'm right I think Milton was like nah
I'm not gonna end up like everybody else it is a wonder that
there were even survivors it's kind of it's actually so sad
that at the very end all you have is dawn and edie and edith
like just three people left in this giant house is so sad
and they louis milton and edith and dawn they all moved
after they're after the dad died right how did odin die
didn't he went down with the house why did I say mailed when
they sailed over?
Yeah.
He went down with his ship.
What an interesting game.
Much to think about.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Our little sad venture that we went on today.
Sad venture games, my beloved.
I wonder if Edie found her father's body in a low tide that
would be so like what if he was what if that light that came
on in the house what if that's where she saw his body that
would be so sad oh that would be oh my god yay thank you I
actually didn't cry I'm surprised but it was It was heavy,
for sure.
I tried to keep these.
I didn't think the whole game would be so heavy, but I try
to keep these kind of lighthearted so we can still have fun
and everything.
Dorigo, thank you for the pig.
Thank you, thank you.
May all the sinister serpents you seek be seen inside a
marvelous and happy dream.
Thank you.
It's a downer of a game.
Yeah, we try to lighten it up, though.
Gotta not cry.
working it's okay it's okay but thank you guys thank you
thank you i'm gonna go get some dinner and i will talk to
you guys when i see you next so thank you so much and i will
see you later thank you everyone thank you so much i will
see you next time take care take care take care take like I
have to be like, don't do anything stupid.
Make good decisions.
Oh, Scarlet, thank you for modding.
I'm going to remove your mod powers now.
Thank you, though.
Thank you, thank you.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
Bye.
Oops.
There we go.
I forgot.
I forgot to change it Okay Bye